[Music]
it's time to make annual predictions for
the new year but before we do that let's
rewind and see how my fellow fibers did
with predictions from a year ago
watch I think one you know it's too much
to ask for impeachment or indictment I
think the Democrats take back the house
and maybe even the Senate number two and
this one's really for my lovely friend
to my left here mr. Jesse Watters
oh no no wall no no wall I believe that
the Washington football team will win a
game in 20 in the Super Bowl this year
and they're probably gonna be playing
the Pats New England I think the Eagles
finally this is gonna be our year we're
gonna bring home the Lombardi Trophy I
think the Bitcoin bubble will burst and
that it will have like far wider
implications to the system than people
realize I think Justice Anthony Kennedy
will retire wow that's a big one and I
think that my sister Angie will get
another cat I will probably become about
35% better-looking maybe 12% funnier in
16% smarter possible with a plus or
minus 3% and I also predict that this
year's Oscars will be the shortest ever
because there will only be four
presenters because everyone else has
fled the country I gotta say pretty darn
good Dana 353 go back of my record over
the years I don't know I'm kind of good
at it I like the Kennedy one I nailed
that that was it that was a good one I
remember I said that there would be a
vacancy the year before and there was
because unfortunately Justice Scalia
passed away and then I said Harry Reid
wouldn't run for re-election when he
didn't so I don't but this year I don't
feel like I have a great handle on
things okay but I can I do mine now
yeah okay sure so I'm gonna say and I
believe that to be true Kate Middleton
will announce she's going to have a
fourth baby Wow and she's pregnant with
her fourth okay I think that free solo
is going to win the documentary of the
year at the Oscars and I think those
brands are going to win the Superbowl
but that doesn't really feel like an
informed opinion if it's coming from me
so I would
waived off of this by my assistant Honda
but I'm going to predict it I think Tom
Brady's going to retire in 2019 I think
he's not gonna he's gonna try to end on
a high note and not do the slow decline
so I'm predicting Tom Brady but you help
out your old friend what is free solo
about well if you paid attention to my
one more things it's a it's a
documentary about a climber who times
without ropes
ok got it solo ok one I mean you said no
wall and well the lights it's you know
even a blind squirrel finds a nut once
in a while people that's alright nuts
because I think Dana is the queen of
predictions I think she's a prophet and
I missed anyway
I would say Harriet Tubman is gonna be
on the $20 bill this year this coming
year how about the car industry because
I don't get it but it having this
experience but people in Pittsburgh tell
me they can just like get in the car
like a cab or an uber and it's no driver
it's just automatic well and this is
gonna I think kind of spread across the
country right now
and then of course New York State wants
to legalize marijuana I think this is no
stopping at this point marijuana is just
I mean in my lifetime some incredible
things have happening like gang legal
gambling everywhere now marijuana is
legal everywhere that's you don't want
to bet what do you mean you suddenly
quit gambling and I yeah and I think the
five is gonna be even more popular in
2019 than it is now because we're gonna
have so much turmoil politically I think
people will be watching for a show like
this political turmoil is a good
prediction for 29 years no doubt Kennedy
all right I think Sheryl Sandberg steps
down at Facebook wow I think Mark
Zuckerberg stays but in a different
title like chairman emeritus I think the
trumps will stay Mary but I think
Melania is going to move back to New
York City Wow and I think that Mara law
marijuana will be rescheduled I don't
think it will be federally legal but I
think it will officially be rescheduled
since there are a majority of states
that have some form of legal cannabis
yeah I think that's right because I
think it would be hard
I don't know Trump might be the guy to
legalize marijuana though yeah you can't
live with that conflict for too long
from the state and federal level right
yes it will come to some sort of an
impasse I also think the house is going
to impeach the president but he will not
be removed
from office interesting Greg I'm going
to stick with my prediction from last
year which was 100% accurate I will
become 35% more attractive over the next
year a little 40% funnier I can't
remember what the third 14 yeah I know
I'm trying no no I don't want to I don't
want to overload people with my wit any
other predictions
I predict that every single one of us
will be forced to apologize for
something because because that's the
wave in the future it'll be apologies
apologies because apologies sell the
media loves it when somebody gets into
trouble and they love hounding them
until you're before it before a camera
saying you're sorry it's gonna happen to
everything you know you're using a plain
mug yes Jesse's not here yes I thought
jesse was on target
the Eagles versus the Patriots and the
Eagles win the Superbowl he could have
made some money in Vegas you probably
did speak of apologizing one of my
prediction is someone at Fox News maybe
someone at this table will be banned by
Twitter or Facebook like censorship of
conservatives in certain speech is
happening and it's can only get worse in
2019 I think Russia and Ukraine are
gonna massively escalations yeah I think
I think it's gonna be Trump Putin NATO
involved we'll see what happens in 2019
Wow
I also disagree with your well you were
right last year in Bitcoin I'm hoping
I'm right this your Bitcoin is going to
rebound
big-time I'm saying 20,000 price-point
by the end of 2019 you're on tape on
tape it's gonna make 16,000 we'll see
you next year we'll see and none of my
Minnesota sports teams will win a title
that's my linen form to make sure at
least one oh grandma